tom brady is the nfl's most disliked
player in the most in most of the nation
studies shows and zenner says uh
that uh brady carried belichick that
check may not even be in the top three
greatest coaches of all time he said he
might not be in top 100 no i never said
that i said he probably is in the top
hundred he probably he is not he's not
proven that to me yet let's let's look
at the body of work when he's done with
his first bill
the fact that he's 10 games under 500
without tom brady means nothing to you
name five better coaches than bill
belichick okay uh sean payton andy reid
don schuler
by the way you didn't even say lombardi
like lombardi is not better than no but
lombardy i don't go back that far i i
prefer to stay more jimmy johnson and
sean payton though yeah those guys you
know what it's easy to just say that and
laugh at me but let's see what he's done
without tom brady when it's all up let
me ask you a different question yeah you
got two choices parcels or belichick who
do you choose uh i would probably pick
parcells i would pick parcells for it
for his ability to build what did
what about the yuri at matt castle brady
was still on that team his presence was
still alive on that roster okay that was
his one winning season without him
look at his record
did you see what he's done so far this
year and last year there's two arguments
here there's two and you know our
audience loves sports
there's there are two arguments here
one of the arguments is the following
one of the arguments is
if belichick standalone argument one of
the greatest coaches of all time if not
the greatest but the second argument is
who carried who brady belichick
the argument of brady belichick right
now it's not even close it's obviously
going to brady he's proven the last two
years as of right now because no way man
by the way isn't belichick right now one
and two they're one and two mack
wait wait but go back to it you're
taking belichick over brady yes
absolutely oh my god here let me ask you
a question if belichick is so smart why
did he get rid of tom brady you doing
that job to drew freaking henson man
if tom brady is a six-round draft pick
of the new york jets he's he's uh he's
on hold you guys no belichick didn't
play
football you're both overreaching this
an act to get a plug for vt sports be
honest
because he's a big entrepreneur the
angriest guy listening to this going
yeah you're right gerard is drew
freaking bledsoe because if marvin lewis
doesn't blow his spleen up drew
bledsoe's got three uh super bowl rings
and he's the king of boston
you guys are acting like i said um les
steckel is the greatest nfl coach of all
time i'm simply saying belichick hasn't
done squat without tom brady nothing
no he didn't he was an assistant coach
he was a defensive coordinator he didn't
win him he was part of a staff that won
a super bowl tom i don't know what
happened with you and and bill belichick
everything we'll work it out don't worry
everything's gonna be okay folks if
you're listening to this by the way for
the for the 20 of you guys that follow
sports here's a question for you thumbs
up if you have a choice
you can pick belichick to build around a
team or brady to pick around the team if
brady is your choice smash thumbs up if
it's belichick you want to build around
a team around a coach put thumbs down
i'm curious to see what happens right
now we've got 112.
i'd be curious you know what people say
yeah but i know we make this joke a lot
that our audience doesn't
for you though but our audi you
generally think our audience doesn't
even like sports a little bit no they
twenty that's why i said twenty percent
i gotta say more than that maybe twenty
two maybe twenty two would be increasing
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you wanna see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]